[Música]
es momento de hablar de economía y me
acompaña nuevamente esta noche de Juan
Pablo lucumi para los detalles Juan
Pablo Buenas noches buenas noches Ángela
vamos a comenzar hablando de Europa los
líderes de la Unión Europea siguen
avanzando Juan Pablo en reuniones para
tratar otra vez de controlar la crisis
energética Así es Ángela Pues esta
semana es decisiva para los líderes del
bloque europeo Pues puntualmente el
próximo jueves definirán Qué hacer para
que los elevados precios de la energía
no afecten aún más los índices
inflacionarios que ya golpea a muchos
países de los 27 lo más difícil en esta
situación es que se pongan de acuerdo
pues algunos líderes quieren imponer un
tope en el precio del gas para mantener
los precios bajos y otros aseguran que
poner un tope impediría el suministro y
agravaría más la situación Este martes
el llamado fue a la unidad y se habló de
la posibilidad que la demanda de energía
del bloque sea conjunta y no individual
sabemos que somos fuertes cuando
actuamos Juntos por lo tanto el primer
énfasis es que hagamos operativa la
compra conjunta en esta propuesta de hoy
sabemos que la demanda de energía de
Europa es muy grande por lo tanto Es
lógico que en lugar de superarnos entre
nosotros los estados miembros y las
empresas energéticas deben aprovechar su
poder adquisitivo conjunto una de las
noticias es de nuestros titulares de hoy
Juan Pablo la huelga de trabajadores en
muchas refinerías de Francia motivó a
que ahora haya protestas en las calles
del país Quienes se han unido para salir
a estas manifestaciones pues Ángela se
trata de personal hospitalario
profesores estudiantes y otros sectores
sindicales que han salido a las calles
en nantes al noroccidente de Francia
reclamándole al gobierno de Emmanuel
macron por mejores salarios una
solicitud que han venido haciendo desde
hace varias semanas el personal de las
refinerías y que ha paralizado casi por
completo el suministro de combustible
protesta está afectando todos los
sectores económicos desde el transporte
hasta las centrales nucleares escuchemos
estamos sobre todo enojados es decir que
ante toda esta pérdida de poder
adquisitivo no hay respuesta de este
gobierno solo responde para decir que la
gente solo está para bloquear pero la
demanda Real de la gente que está en las
calles es el poder adquisitivo y el
aumento salarial los jefes de las
empresas son los que más dinero se meten
en el bolsillo con los accionistas y
luego los empleados somos los que
tenemos que compensar la inflación con
nuestro poder adquisitivo y vamos a
cambiar nuevamente de tema este próximo
8 de noviembre estaremos haciendo el
cubrimiento de las elecciones de mitad
de término en Estados Unidos los
votantes Están preocupados por la
situación económica del país cuéntenos
por favor pues Ángela nada más ayer
hablábamos de que bloomberry economics
dice que en los próximos 12 meses
Estados Unidos tiene una probabilidad
del 100% de caer en recesión eso es uno
de los anuncios y reportes que pues les
preocupan a los estadounidenses según
estudios la inflación es la principal
preocupación a la hora de votar seguida
de la economía y el empleo pero veamos
más en el informe de
Manuel a casi tres semanas de las
elecciones de medio término la situación
económica de Estados Unidos es uno de
los temas clave de la agenda política y
es que la amenaza de una posible
recesión está cada vez más vigente Y la
inflación continúa siendo alta con el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
un 13,5% en los últimos 12 meses los
sondeos de opinión muestran que la
economía es la prioridad número uno de
los votantes
algunas de las novedades de estas
elecciones de medio mandato son los
temas que importan a los votantes en
esta ocasión es la inflación la
inflación ha sido del 9% año tras año y
eso está realmente en la mente de la
gente
según una encuesta decidies news el 68%
de los estadounidenses estima que el
gobierno de jovaden podría hacer más
para combatir la inflación un argumento
de peso para los adversarios del
presidente que le acusan de minimizar
dificultades económicas de los
estadounidenses
le preocupa la fortaleza del dólar en
estos momentos
no me preocupa la fortaleza del dólar me
preocupa el resto del mundo tiene
sentido puede explicarlo
Sí nuestra economía es muy fuerte y la
inflación está en todo el mundo está
peor en todas las otras partes que en
Estados Unidos así que el problema Es la
falta de crecimiento económico y de
políticas sólidas en otros países no
tanto en el nuestro las elecciones del 8
de noviembre en las que los votantes
eligen a los congresistas y gobernadores
se celebran dos años después de las
presidenciales y son una suerte de
referéndum sobre la política del
mandatario de turno a finales de agosto
los demócratas vieron sus esperanzas
aumentar respecto a la posibilidad de
conservar una mayoría en el senado e
incluso en la cámara de representantes
pero las últimas encuestas indican que
los votantes independientes cruciales en
un contexto de fuerte polarización
inclinar la balanza a favor de los
republicanos
es el momento de los indicadores Así es
Ángela pues Wall Street cerró con sus
tres principales indicadores en terreno
positivo luego de que muchas empresas
estadounidenses empezaran a reportar
grandes ganancias en el tercer trimestre
de este año Europa siguió la senda
alcista de Estados Unidos y pues esta
fue la cuarta sesión consecutiva de
ganancias también luego de que algunos
resultados empresariales pues estuvieran
mejor de lo esperado y motivaron a los
inversionistas una caída en el precio
del gas también afectó las decisiones de
los compradores y su cifra por favor 2,4
millones de suscriptores sumó El gigante
de streaming Netflix entre julio y
septiembre para un total de 223 millones
de clientes en todo el mundo esto tras
casi un año de pérdida de suscriptores
debido a la llegada de nuevas
plataformas que han sido una competencia
y han hecho que los usuarios migran de
aplicación y ahí nos tienen a todos
pegados Así es Gracias Juan Pablo usted
y vamos ahora con el debate vamos
[Música]